what do you put in terms of odds that
the merge happens before year end cause
i let me explain this way i think the
eth community would say very high odds i
think the bitcoin community say very low
odds and that's just the nature of
tribalism etc like
how do you think about what the actual
odds are that that occurs this year
i think it's about 90 percent
um the east community is talking about
august i think is more realistic they
have a tendency of always being late so
i think october to november and and some
something that happened and basically
things gonna be late again it makes
sense
so that's why i'm saying somewhere
between august uh sorry october and
november
um i think that makes sense and i put
the likelihood of it being really this
year extremely high
uh the thing i'm concerned about is
there's two things one is
i mean i think is i hope it doesn't
happen but it i think it's very real
that
let's say 30 50 60 i don't know the
probability but there's a real uh
scenario where basically we go through a
repeat
of
2018 basically uh q4 and crypto just
collapses uh hope doesn't happen can
happen
um so uh in in that scenario the
marriage is gonna be absolutely relevant
nobody's gonna care about it in one hand
on the other hand
uh if uh basically if we're in a proper
for a bear market as this continues
um
activity in the ethereum blockchain is
gonna
it's gonna be very low
so the uh the the the yield that we're
gonna get on on east is gonna be
considerably lower
and it's not gonna be as attractive so
it's kind of like a feedback loop no hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time